I want to find out the ability of the lotus. Shoot while standing toward the target.
Semi-automatically shoot 10 shots slowly.
10 shots are not possible.
Goo Drag Still full power.
If you touch, come back with
full power.
Pro to the result of the lie Immediately road to
Neo Shake your head and walk as normally as possible
And always turn to the angle told by each instruction
Send a signal and at the same time stand up and rush down again with the
next soybean
If you walk as fast as you can in the back, you'll just spin and get hungry.
Crouch down and curl
up.
ebr
ebr is an acronym for a house degree battle rifle-an
enhanced version of the old rifle-the
scene is 7.62mm and
n's fighting style seems to be semi-automatic
I basically keep a distance from the opponent  I want to fight
I use ebr even at a dog distance, but this is it in the vagina etc.
hk 45
German 45 caliber magazine capacity 10 shots
I want you to remember this lever in case the safety device is in trouble
Do you have any other questions?
I'm the leader of the strategy goal
I can take the actual strategy command
What's in it?